.
de la mer et se détendre sur
lalalalage. Un geste simple,
un répit essentiel après presque
trois mois de guerre.llllllllll.
À Odessa, le bord de mer
est une zone interdite.
Car la ville portuaire vit
depuis févrierququququququququqt
ssssssssssa, le bord de mer
est une zone interdite.
Car la ville portuaire vit
d'un débarquement russe etesese.
Même les statues et monuments
y sont protégés.
Le quartier où habitent
Viktoria Lysiuk et sa fille
Nikole, est l'unibibibibibibibi.
Mais il est aujourd'hui
méconnaiss
"C'était irréel au début,
on s'y fait. C'est devenu
notr r r r r r réalité."
Viktoria s'est habituée aussi
aux pénuries de carburant et aux
produits manquants à l'épice
Mais la peur de la guerre,
"Quanuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiu,
c'est très difficile, dit-elle.
On espère vraiment rester
en paix parce que c'est
Connue comma a a a a a a a a ae
son riche patrimoine
architectural et culturel.
Fière de son identité unique.
Et si senenenenenenen 2014 à rn
et à la fièvre séparatiste,
ils sont bien conscients que
leur ville fait maintenant face
à l'une des menaces les plus
graves
C'est la raison pour laquelle
Aleksandr Synytskyy a décidérrrr
volontaire pour défendre v v v .
Depuis, il monte la garde
tous les jours sur ce point de
contrôle à deux pas de l'opéra.
qui l'étonne lui-même.
"Avant le début de la guerre,
vu faire ce que je fais
actuellement."
C'est qu'Aleksandr n'est pas un
va-t'en guerre, loin s'en fandn,
il se décrit comme un pacifiste.
"Il n'y a pas de justification
pour la guerre, peu importe,
celle-ci."
Aleksandr n'est pas un
un conscrit. C'est donc den n nn
uniforme chaque jour et retourne
à son poste de garde après
so
Une routine immuable depuis
il s'agit de défendre ses
concitoyens, une identité,
mais aussi u
Car pour Aleksandr, l'Ukraine
est un exemple d'ouverture
et de to
"Je peux parler ukrainien,
mais ma langue m j j j j j j j s
je ne me suis senti opprimé
en Ukraine quand je parle
russe", dit-il.
Alors, il interpelle les
sold,,,,,,,,,,
autrefois peuple frère.
"Posez-vous simplement cette
questiPoPoPoPoPoPoPoPoPoPour
quelle cause vous battez-vous?"
Parce que pour Aleksandr,
comme pour tous les habitants
d'Odessa, la réponse est très
claire. Et elle vaut tous
I